durante una misa dominical en la iglesia
copta de abu si fin en giza se produjo
un incendio poco antes de las nueve de
la mañana los pisos superiores de la
iglesia albergan una guardería y se cree
que la mayoría de las víctimas eran
niños y cómo sacaban a los muertos del
piso superior asfixia asfixia todos
muertos y niños no sabíamos cómo llegar
a ellos y no sabemos de quién es este
hijo o de quiénes está ahí
empezamos a ver desde fuera que las
nubes de humo se hacían más grandes y la
gente quería saltar desde incluso
superior desde el edificio de la iglesia
de al lado y uno lo hizo entonces
entramos y encontramos a los niños y
empezamos a sacar los cuerpos
5000 personas se agolpaban para asistir
a la misa cuando se produjo la
conflagración la entrada quedó bloqueada
y se produjo una estampida se ha
iniciado una investigación que sugiere
que la causa pudo ser un cortocircuito
eléctrico
el presidente del fatah el cis ya ha
declarado que ha movilizado a todos los
servicios estatales para hacer frente al
incendio y ha tuiteado sus condolencias
a las familias de las víctimas más tarde
dijo que había telefoneado al papa copto
segundo el gran imán de al azhar la
principal institución musulmana egipcia
se unió al presidente para expresar sus
condolencias subrayando que los
hospitales de al azar están preparados
para recibir a las víctimas el gobierno
regional ha anunciado un paquete de
ayuda financiera para los heridos y las
familias de los fallecidos